[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيه بودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي
تلونت صفحات الاعلام ومنصات التواصل
الاجتماعي بكلمات التهنئه لمختلف انواع
النساء ام كانت او زوجه اخت او ابنه ولكن
كاي مناسبه لابد النا من جرده حساب
باعتبار انه احنا منحتفل بعام جديد المراه
حول العالم قطعت اشواط طويله في مجالات
مختلفه وباتت اليوم موجوده ومؤثره في
موقعها ايا كان هذا الموقع ولانه احنا
بصدد حساب مكاسب المراه من خساراتها فقررت
اني ابحث في مجال الرياضه وتحديدا الرياضه
النسويه من دون شك بيتنا في السنوات
العشره الاخيره بنشوف اخبار وتغطيات
للرياضات النسويه وبطلاتها اكتر بكتير من
قبل
الكثير من المتابعين والمتابعات بشوفوا
انه الرياضات النسويه مثيره وبتستحق
المتابعه ويمكن خير دليل على ذلك هو
ارتفاع نسب متابعه البطلات والفرق النسويه
عامه وهو امر كان مفقود الحقيقه في الماضي
القريب وهذا بيحد ذاته علامه انتصار تحسب
لهاي الصناعه كتير من الناس بيعزوا السبب
في ذلك لا منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
واسهامها في تسليط الضوء على الرياضات
سواء كانوا افراد ام فرق
واحنا ما بنحتاج انه نكون انفسنا رياضيين
لحتى نتابع فريق او بطله خصوصا وانه كتير
من الرياضيين ذكور كانوا وام ايناس باتوا
اكثر تاثيرا في مجالات انسانيه بتتعدى
حدود الرياضه
ويمكن من اجمل الامثله على ذلك هو لاعب
نادي مانشستر يونايتد
واللي اصبح ناشط اجتماعي خصوصا خلال فتره
انتشار وباء كوفيد بحيث حثت مبادرته
الانسانيه الحكومه البريطانيه لدفع اكثر
من 400 مليون جنيه استرليني لدعم وجبات
الطعام المجانيه لاطفال المدارس كذلك
بطلتنا العربيه في التنس انس جابر اللي
قامت ببيع مضربها اللي انتصرت فيه على
البطل العالميه الامريكيه فينوس
وتبرعت بثمنه للمستشفيات التونسيه ابان
الازمه نفسها هذه اسباب كافيه لكثير من
الناس اللي ما بيهتموا بالضروره بالرياضه
لكنهم بتابعوا الرياضيين
بتتعدى اللعبه نفسها لحتى ندخل بتفاصيل
اكثر متابعينا الكرام بحب ارحب بضيفي في
الاستوديو الاستاذ محمد حامد الصحفي
الرياضي اهلا وسهلا فيك معنا في كلام
منطقي استاذ محمد اهلا وسهلا واشكركم على
الدعوه الكريمه واشكركم لطرح هذه القضيه
وخلينا نقول سريعا ان القضيه طرحت من قبل
بس ان شاء الله تناول اليوم يكون مختلف هو
انا لفتني هذا الموضوع وحبيت اني ابدا معك
في قبل ما نكمل سرد القصه زي ما بعمل بكل
حلقه بشكل تفصيلي لمتابعينا الكرام كنا عم
نتحدث انا واياك قبل قليل قبل ما نبلش
التسجيل وكنت عم تخبرني بانه هذا الموضوع
طرح وناقش او تم نقاشه في وسائل الاعلام
ولكن دائما ما يكون النقاش خجول غير كافي
غير عميق وغير جاد بتمنى انه نقدر نلقي
الضوء بعكس هذه الاوصاف اليوم ان شاء الله
ليه بتقول هيك
يعني بحكم التخصص يعني دايما وهقول لك
امتى تحديدا مع بدايه الدورات الاولمبيه
او بطولات عالم يكون فيها مشاركه نسائيه
عربيه بنبدا كل مره احنا كناس بنشتغل في
الميديا الرياضيه تحديدا نطرح القضيه طيب
احنا عندنا كم بطله عربيه مشاركه في
الاولمبيك جيمز السنه دي مثلا او في
الدوره دي طب مين منهم مرشح انه ممكن يجيب
لي
ميداليه دهبيه بنوصل في النهايه انه ان
المساله فيها فيها حاله يعني فيها حاله من
عدم اليقين باي شيء يعني صعب جدا ان احنا
نتوقع بطلات عربيات حتى الى الان رغم ان
في حاله من التقدم النسبي يعني
فبنروح للخطوه التاليه ان احنا نطرح
القضيه بشكل نحاول نطرح القضيه بشكل فيه
جديه شويه طب ايه اللي بيحصل
لحد ما نصطدم بفكره خلينا نقول
الذكوريه ذكوريه المجتمع او انه دايما
الراجل او الولد او الشاب عنده فرصه اكبر
لممارسه رياضه على مستوى البطوله عنده
فسحه خلينا نقول اجتماعيه اكتر انه يبرز
في هذا المجال ضغوط الاهل على الولد غير
البنت كل ده كل الكلام ده كله موجود ولابد
نعترف به بس خلينا مع مسار النقاش نصل الى
نقاط اهم واعمق فيما يتعلق برياده المراه
للاسف وبالرغم من تقدم الرياضه النسويه
وتحقيقها لقفزات نوعيه الا انه الطريق ما
زال طويل بالطبع هناك دول بتتقدم اسرع من
غيرها والولايات المتحده يمكن هي احدى هاي
الدول خصوصا في رياضه كره القدم
بحيث ساوى الاتحاد الامريكي ما بين
المنتخب النسوي والذكوري في الجوائز
المقدمه خصوصا بعد فوز المنتخب النسائي
بكاس العالم في عام 2022
بيتوقع المدير التنفيذي لدوري رياضه
الركبي الانجليزي
انه القيمه التجاريه للرياضه النسويه ممكن
تتضاعف ثلاث مرات بحلول عام 2030 اذا ما
تم دعمها بالشكل الكافي
جيدا وهي منصه بحثيه متخصصه في بريطانيا
بتشير الى بحث اجرته العام الماضي عام
2022 يبين الاختلافات في عدد المشاهدين
ومتابعين الرياضات النسويه وهي للاسف تعطي
اشارات متضاربه بتقول المنصه انه من السهل
القول انه نسب النمو لهذه السنه مقارنه
باللي سبقتها في البلدان اللي بنتابعها
ارتفعت خصوصا في المملكه المتحده
لهاي الرياضات بتقول منصه جي دبليو اي انه
62% من محبي الرياضه من الجنسين بشوفوا
انه الرياضه النسويه لابد ان تاخذ مساحه
اكبر في الاعلام واستثمارات اكثر من
الشركات فالشركات اللي بتتغنى بالمساواه
ما بين الجنسين لا تترجم كلامها رياضيا
فهل هذه هي القطعه الوحيده المفقوده في
اللوحه
للاسف لا خلينا نبدا بشو وين مواطن الخلل
هل المواطن الخلل في عدم اقبال الفتيات
خلينا نحكي عن عمر صغير على الرياضه
وبالتالي بعد ما يوصلوا لسن معين يحترفوا
هاي الرياضه للاسباب اللي ذكرتها منها
المجتمع والاهل وما الى ذلك ولا المشكله
في عدم القاء الضوء على هذه الرياضه
النسائيه من قبل وسائل الاعلام فبالتالي
ببطل في اهتمام من قبل الفتيات في هذا
الموضوع يمكن هذا هو السؤال الابرز انه
مين من اتى قبل الاخر
البيضه ام الدجاجه يعني
اللي صعبه نوصل فيها لشيء محدد يعني في
النهايه هنوصل لمساله ان هي وجهات مصر بس
خلينا نتكلم بوقعيه وبصراحه اكتر
الدوره الاولمبيه الاولمبي كام سنه 1900
اقيمت في باريس دي اول مره السيدات او
الفتيات يشاركوا فيها كانت نسبه مشاركتهم
2.2% الى نسبه الرجال المشاركين طوكيو
اللي هي اخر دوره اولمبيه نسبه مشاركه
السيدات وصلت الى 49% طب هذا تقدم رائع
تقريبا النصف غير عادي احنا على مستوى
العربي احرزنا نفس التقدم بنفس الكيفيه
ونفس الدرجه انا اشك مشكله الرياضه
النسائيه على المستوى العربي اكثر وضوح
معرفش اذا احنا بنتكلم في الجزئيه دي
تحديدا يعني تعتريها بعض المشكلات على
المستوى العالمي ولكن عربيا المشكله واضحه
بشكل غير قابل للجدل خلينا نقوم
اجتماعيه ثقافيه عنا بالعالم العربي اكثر
من اي شيء اخر بمعنى
البنات او الفتيات بيمارسوا رياضه انا
بناتي يمارسوا رياضه وانا ادعي ان انا
راجل عندي درجه من الثقافه ودرجه من
التعقل ودرجه من الانفتاح وكذا واعيش في
مجتمع يدعم هذه القيم
خلينا نقول لغايه 10 او 12 سنه وكان في
ليفل كويس يعني يعني في السباحه في جمباز
ما تعرفيش ايه حصل بعد كده مساله
الاستمراريه لدرجه انها توصل لليفل بطوله
هي فقدت الشغف او تغيرت اهتماماتها
الاهتمامات الدراسه ضغطت انا للامانه ما
طلبتش الحاله من التوقف او كذا ما تعرفيش
يعني بنتاخد اكتر يعني لما البنت بتوصل
لمرحله عمريه معينه
خليني اقول لك علشان تكون بطله محتاجه
سبورت غير عادي من الاهل طبعا محتاج
الكونوا مؤمنين بها جدا محتاجه يكونوا حوا
عشان تقدر تشارك في مسابقات وبطولات
وتمرين وكذا سيترك ابنته مثلا تسافر
وتشارك في بطولات وكذا دون ان يكون داعم
لها من خلال تواجده معاها حتى يعني في هي
المساله اصعب بالنسبه للولد او الشاب لديه
فسحه او لديه مساحه من الحريه اكبر بتتيح
لي انه خليني اقول لك ان في بعض الرياضات
عشان تكون بطل لازم لازم تتدرب ست ساعات
مدخله ست ساعات تدريبيه في اليوم في اليوم
الواحد تعمل اي اشي تاني يعني الولد
خلاص نستطيع ان نتركه زي ما بنقول يعتمد
على نفسه يستغرق ما يستغرق من عدد ساعات
في ممارسه لعبته مساله السفر لما يوصل
للمشاركه في البطولات ففي حاله تفضيليه
حاصله لمصلحه
اتفق معك بشكل كبير يعني اعتقد بانه ما
تقوله صحيح وواقع ولكن في احنا تغيرنا
احنا كمجتمع عربي وصار في انفتاح وصار في
نوع من انواع الدعم
معلش اسالك نسبه اكيد مش زي الغرب ولكن
ومش زي الولد ومش زي مساحه الحريه
الممنوحه للشاب فبالتالي لازال هناك نوع
من الخلل حينما نقارن بين الجنسين في
رياضه البطوله هلا انه الاهل عاده بينظروا
للموضوع ما بياخدوا الاهتمام الرياضي
لبناتهم بالشكل الجدي زي ما لو كان احد
ابنائهم لانه في النهايه اذا احترف مثلا
اي ابنهم كره القدم راح يصير شيء راح
يكونوا فخورين راح يكون غني راح يكون
مشهور بينما فرص الاحتراف قلبي كثير
بالنسبه للنساء بيلاقوها مضيعه على الوقت
يعني نوعا مش مساله مواضيع الوقت لو رحنا
للبطلات يعني حتى على مستوى
الاولمبيك جيمس دايما مقياس لانه اهم ليفل
رياضي تنافسه هو رياض الاولمبيه او
الدورات الاولمبيه احنا ممكن نعد تخيلي لك
ان تتخيلي كم دوره اولمبيه من عام 1900 من
عام 1996 الى عشرين عشرين بانتظام تقام
الدورات الاولمبيه كل اربع سنوات
يعني اكتر من عشرين دوله اولمبيه الا لم
تخن الذاكره يعني
بطل عربيه يعني خمس او ست بطلات فقط وقفنا
على منصه التتويج يعني رقم مهجل للامانه
يعني وبنتكلم عن 22 دوله عربيه يعني
نجله ذاتنا ما احنا اصلا الرياضات العربيه
بشكل عام حتى الذكوريه متاخره نوعا عن
بقيه العالم
صحيح
لا لا متفق متفق معك بس بس احنا بنتكلم عن
اربع خمس بطلات حصلنا على ميداليات ذهبيه
انا عايز اقول نقطه مهمه هنا ان دول
خلينا نقول
جهد فردي ظاهره فرديه ما كانش وراها دوله
داعمه ما كانش وراها سيستم يكتشف مواهب ما
كانش وراها حاله اجتماعيه بتدعم البنت
عشان تروح لمستوى البطوله انا شفت ودققت
في كل واحده منهم نوال المتوكل اعتقد
حبيبه الغريبي
حسيبه بالماركه حتى من سوريا غاده غاده
شعاع اعتقد هم وسموها حتى في سوريا البطله
القرن او بطله سوريا التاريخيه هي حاله
فرديه بالمناسبه طيب عارفه ايه الدليل
انها حاله فرديه لماذا لم تنتج بطلات
اخريات لماذا لم تكن هناك عدوى لظهور
المزيد من البطلات يفترض انه انه انه لما
بيجي يعني مثلا خلينا نقول حاله محمد صلاح
في مصر او غيره من النجوم العرب اللي في
ملاعب اوروبا
بالكامل ملهم بكم ملهم يبقى بيتبقى عليا
هديكي مثال بسيط في مصر بعد حاله محمد
صلاح قالوا خلونا نعمل مشروع لاكتشاف
لاعب كره قدم وهنبقى مصدرين للهجوم كره
القدم زي البرازيل طيب محمد صلاح اكثر من
عشر سنوات في ملعب اوروبا اين ذهب المشروع
الذي تحدثتم عنه ففي كمان جانب عايز اقول
لاختصار في جانب مؤسسي كمان تقصير مؤسس
الدوله العام وحكومه للاهتمام بهذه
بالرياضات النسائيه والرياضات بشكل عام
والرياضات النسائيه يعني ببساطه اقدر
اساعد البنت ان انا مثلا دراسيا مثلا ان
لما بتوصل لمستوى معين من التفوق الرياضي
او مستوى البطوله اساعدها في دراسيا في
موضوع درجات تفوق مثلا يعني لكن تتخيلي في
ثانويه عامه اللي هي بعبع
كل العرب فتيات وشباب
باجي في المرحله دي اللي هي مرحله تكوين
البطل او مرحله دخول اللاعب او اللاعبه
لمستوى البطوله ايه المانع ان انا ادعمه
من في امنحه درجات تفوق رياضي
تغنيه عن فكره او تديه هالانس اكثر في
المواائمه والموازنه ما بين
الساعات اللي بيمضيها لكي يكون بطل وما
يجب عليه في مساله الدراسه وتحصل الدراسي
واحد من الحلول يعني كم دوله عربيه لجات
الى هذا الحل لم نكن ابدا جديين في هذا
المسار
التوقعات المستقبليه للرياضه النسويه تعد
بنجاحات عديده لكن اين نحن اليوم من هذه
النجاحات لابد انه نبدا بقياس الفرق ما
بين الرجال والنساء
فته 86% من الرجال بيتابعوا الرياضه
عالميا بينما 72% فقط بيفعلوا اشياء ذاته
هذا على المستوى العالمي يمكن في عالمنا
العربي نسبه النساء المتابعات راح تكون
اقل لكن هناك فروق كبيره في نوع المنافسات
اللي بشاهدها كلا الجنسين فتسعه من الرجال
بفضلوا متابعه الدوريات والبطولات
الرجاليه فقط بينما بتفضل النساء البطولات
والرياضات المختلطه واللي هي النسبه
العالميه على الاقل هي 72% النسب السابقه
بتعود لطبيعه الرياضه اللي يفضل متابعتها
كلا الجنسين فمتابعات الرياضه من النساء
بفضلوا بطولات تزلج على الجليد مثلا
الجمباز السباحه والريشه وعلى النقيض
فالذكور بفضلوا الملاكمه وكره القدم
وسباقات السيارات
والمصارعه المشكله طبعا تكمن في انه هذه
الرياضات اللي بتابعها ذكور لا تفسح
المجال لاعطاء النساء مساحه اكبر في
الانضمام اليها
فان كان العالم صادقا فعلا في محاولته
للمساومه بين الرجال والنساء رياضيا على
الاقل اذا يتعين على بعض الرياضات انها
تعمل اكثر لتسهيل الطريق على الاناث
للانضمام اليها وكاس العالم الماضي يمكن
ضرب مثال رائع في اضافه حكام اناث لبعض
الرياضات هل زادت برايك
الاهتمام بالرياضات النسائيه عالميا عندنا
سؤال انا اسمحيلي تكوني ضيفتي في السؤال
ده
انت محتاجه الرياضه النسائيه
اللي هو الليفل اللي خلينا نقول
يعني احنا داخلين في منافسه مع بعض
رجال ونساء واللي احنا ولا احنا رايحين
لفكره انه انه الفتاه او البنت او السيده
تمارس الرياضه اللي تناسب طبيعتها كسيده
بتكون ملهمه فيها اكتر على فكره ده سؤال
مهم بس بسالك اه يعني هو ده سؤال مهم هقول
لك ليه قبل ما تجاوبيني لو تسمحيني
النجمه الرومانيه ناديه في الاولمبيك جيمز
اعتقد 78 في السبعينات
حصلت على
عشره من عشره
عمرها ما حصلت في تاريخ التنافس الاولمبي
وخاصه في الرياضات الجمباز ان حد يكون ان
حد ياخد الدرجه النهائيه الفضل هنا يعود
لها وتدريبها ومهارتها لكن جزء من الفضل
يعود لفكره انها تفوقت في رياضه تناسبها
اكتر انا كرجل يشدني انجاز زي ده لكن فكره
انها تمارس رياضه اخرى اقرب الى عالم
الرجال زي كره القدم مثلا ممكن ما تشدنيش
بشكل كافي الاسم لازال اسمها ناديه
كوماتشي لازال من اهم الاسماء اللي بتتردد
على مسامع وفي اذهان الجميع حققت انجاز
يناسبها اكتر كسيده بتمارس رياضه مناسبه
لها اكثر انا انا مش بضغط في طريق الاجابه
بس انا بقول لك بقائع يعني
يعني انا اتفهم بانه احنا اكيد في فروق
فسيولوجيه ما بين الرجل والمراه
بتخلي انهم يعني تنافسهم في ذات الرياضه
او في ذات المجال
يعني اللي اللي
بحاجه لاستخدام الفسيولوجيا صعبه جدا يعني
انت ما بتقدر تقارن البرتقال بالتفاح لا
يقارنه
فكره ان انا اكون فخور ان انا عندي فارق
قوه طبيعي ملهاش معنى كرجل يعني يعني مثلا
لما لما بيلعب الكره مثلا اقصى قوه مثلا
نقول 160 سرعتها 160 في التنس مثلا سيرين
ويليامز اقوى سيده تمارس اللعبه اكيد في
فاروق 120 130 هذه الفروق هي الفروق
طبيعيه هل لا يمكن ان تقارن البرتقال مع
التفاح هما مختلفين فسيولوجيا حضرتك يا
سيده هل بتستمتعي برياضه بتستمتعي برياضه
التنس مع السرينه وفينس
والنجمات اكتر من استمتاعك او بدرجه
موازيه لاستمتاعنا بافادر جوكوفاكشن لما
يمارسوا نفس اللعبه سؤال اخر يعني اعتقد
استمتعهم انه استمتع فيهم بنفس الطريقه
انا ما اقوله بانه لا نستطيع يعني هو في
رياضات مختلفه وعلى ما يبدو النساء بحسب
بحثي بفضله انهم يتابعوا الرياضات
المختلطه اكثر من الرياضات النسائيه
على يعني بشكل خاص ولكن انا يعني ملاقيه
من غير المنطقي انك تحط رجل وامراه يتنافس
في مجال الرياضه الا اذا كانت الرياضه
تحديدا لا تعتمد على
الفسيولوجيا بدرجه بالدرجه الكبيره
مثل مثلا قياده السيارات او او غيرها من
الرياضات اللي في سباقات الفورمه ما هذا
هو سؤالي لماذا يعني احنا مش عم نحكي عن
رياضات
سابق المنافسه فيها صعب
مش مسيولوجيه يعني يعني حتى احنا مش
عايزين مش عايزين نوصل للمستويات اعمق في
مساله فروق او كذا يا استاذ محمد يعني هيك
معناته النساء ما فيش داعي يدخلوا لمجال
الرياضه اذا هيك طب ايه يعني في في رياضات
تنافسيه لفرق نسائيه نساء ينافسون نساء
فين المشكله في ذلك لانه في تكافؤ
بالقدرات
كره القدم لماذا كره القدم انا انا والله
والله يعني انا نفسي اكون انتصر اكثر
الفكره رياضه المره لاننا مؤمن بها جدا بس
انا عندي وجهه نظر معينه فيها وانا قلتها
يعني لما بنتكلم عن كاس العالم لكره القدم
يعني يعني شفت شفت مدى الاقبال لدرجه ان
ان بطوله رياضيه تنتقل الى حياه اجتماعيه
اصبحت جزء من حياتنا الاجتماعيه وليس لها
وليس فقط هي مجرد رياضه يعني
كاس العالم الاخير في قطر الكميه الفتيات
والسادات اللي بيتفرجوا على بطوله كاس
العالم لكره القدم يكاد يتفوق على نسبه
الرجال فقط في تلك الفتره ما بيتابعوا اي
نوع من انواع الرياضات في اي وقت برشلونه
ريال مدريد يعني مباريات كلاسيكو كذا
لما يكون منتخب عربي مثلا لديه مباراه
كبرى في تحدي كروي ما لكن هو برضو السؤال
فين نسبه السيدات بلاش السيدات فين نسبه
الرجال حتى الرجال او سيدات اللي بيتابعوا
كاس العالم او مونديال السيدات
تقريبا ما فيش مقارنه يمكن اغلب النساء ما
بيعرفوا انه كان في مونديال للسيدات لكره
القدم بسنه الماضيه 2022 والفريق الامريكي
هو اللي فاز علما بانه الفريق النسائي
لكره القدم الامريكي المنتخب هو اللي فاز
علما بانه الفريق الرجالي يعني ترتيبه في
منتخبات العالم
الماضيه
جدا بالظبط يعني يعني هي في حاله هناك
لدينا حاله انتصرت فيها المراه لبلد كامل
في رياضه معينه لما حصل نوع من الاهتمام
بهذه الرياضه في الولايات المتحده لديهم
دوري قوي جدا يعني يعني زي البريميرليج
والليجا اللي هي دوريات الرجال في اوروبا
يعادلها الدوري الامريكي
فالاهتمام بهذه اللعبه على المستوى
النسائي امريكا كوفيات من خلاله يعني
اصبحت بطل العالم في كره القدم النسائيه
يعني اذا لما اهتمينا بفيلد رياضي معين
للسيدات في بلد معين في مكافاه للبلد انها
اهتمت بهذا المجال وزي ما انت قلت حضرتك
انه في فرق كبير بين الرجال والسيدات في
كره القدم في الولايات المتحده المنتخب
الرجال
ترتيبه عادي جدا واداءه عادي جدا في الوقت
اللي كان كله مباراه يرسل رساله الى
الفريق الرجالي هو ترند هو يعني
الميديا والجمهور مهتم بايه اكتر الشيء
اللي بيدفع للتفاؤل هو انه اغلب الناس من
الجنسين بظنوا وبيعتقدوا انه الرياضيات
الاناث لابد انه يحصلوا على مكافات توازي
نظرائهم من الذكور على الاقل اذا كانوا
بيلعبوا نفس الرياضه المضحك انه 89 في
الميه من الناس عامه من غير المتابعين
للرياضه بصروا انهم بيشوفوا انه اللاعبين
من كلا الجنسين لا بد انه يكافئوا بنفس
المقدار وبيعتقدوا ايضا انه هناك اهميه
كبيره لتسليط الضوء على الرياضه النسويه
لزياده قاعده المتابعين وللاسف طبعا اصابع
الاتهام دائما ما تتجه للاعلام ودوره ففي
بحث لجامعه بردو الامريكيه تم التطرق
لجوده التغطيه الاعلاميه للرياضه النسويه
مقارنه بالذكوريه وتم وصفها بالضعيفه
والخجوله هاي المقارنه المستمره في نوعيه
التغطيه ما بين الجنسين هي مشكله بحد
ذاتها فنوعيه التغطيه لابد انها تتساوى
كنقطه مبدئيه لكن اسلوبها لا بد انه يختلف
فما يثير انتباه الذكور مختلف عما يثير
انتباه الاناث وهذا باعتقادي يمكن من اهم
النقاط يجب اخذها بعين الاعتبار كذلك لابد
انه نجد طرق جديده لجذب المهتمات
والمهتمين هل هو دور ومسؤوليه وسائل
الاعلام بانها تلقي الضوء بشكل اكبر على
الرياضات النسائيه لحتى تساهم في دعم
المتابعه لالها ام انه هو العكس هم يحركهم
رغبه المتابعه سؤال جميل انت قدامك
طريقتين وانت اكيد عارفه الكلام ده يمكن
اكتر مني كمان
قدامك طريق ان انا امشي في التراك اللي
يرضي الجمهور
واتناول قضايا جماهيريه واشتغل على فكره
الترند وخلاص انا سوبر ستار والحياه زي
الفل عندي طريق تاني ان انا اخد الناس
لقضايا مهمه مش شايفينها الطريق ده هيبقى
اطول شويه هو اصعب واصعب وممكن انا في
منتصف الطريق اهبط لا استطيع استكمال قضيه
الرياضه النسائيه بالظبط ينطبق عليها
معقوله يعني احنا لو جينا مثلا في قناه
مثلا خلينا نقول قناه رياضيه انا اتحداك
والله لو تم عمل حمله اعلاميه معينه
واعلانات قبل مونديال مثلا السيدات لكره
القدم مثلا
يعني يعمل برومو يعمل تقديمات يجيب ناس
تتكلم عن اهميه البطوله يبتدي يتكلم عن
نجمات في منتخبات مختلفه يتكلم عن كره
القدم مثلا في على مستوى العربي لاعبات
عربي
مش مش هنوصل لمستوى مونديال الرجال بس في
النهايه هيكون فيه اهتمام في النهايه
نعم خليني اقول هنا ان احنا
بنعمل شيء اقرب الى خلق حاله من الاهتمام
مش لان دايما المسار التاني اسهل ان انا
زي ما بنقول اروح معك
واكون جزء منه وابتدي ازايد وابتدي ده
طريق سهل لكن الطريق الاخر اكثر صعوبه
ولكنه اكيد
اكثر متعه
واكثر شرف للاعلامي انه يخلق حاله من
الاهتمام بمجال معين الان بعد ظهور طبعا
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وصار فيه كتير
ناس بتتابع بطلات
رغم انه هن يعني غير مهتمين بالرياضه ولكن
بتابعوها بشكل شخصي على حساباتها على
السوشيال ميديا قديش سوشيال ميديا فتحت
مجال واعطت امل بانه لا هذا الاهتمام ممكن
انه يتوسع ويزيد ومش بالضروره يكون
بشكل جماعي يعني كفريق رياضي او اهتمام
برياضه معينه ولكن
بشخص وشخصيات البطلات النساء الرياضيات
تعلق الناس وخاصه في مرحله الطفوله خلينا
نقول وبدايات الشباب سواء للفتيات او
الشباب بالابطال الرياضيين بالايقونز
مساله مهمه جدا يعني لك ان تدخلي دايما
البطل او البطله
متابعينه كميه متابعينه والزخم الذي يخلقه
هو اهم حتى من المؤسسه اللي بينتمي اليها
يعني يعني دائما البطل او البطله بيلعب
لنادي معين او بتلعب لنادي معين هتكشف
مثلا لمتابعينه اكتر من النادي نفسه ده
معناه ايه ده معناه ان الشخص كفره هو
تاثيره اكبر او غيره او حتى السرينه يعني
يعني ملايين بيتابعوها دي بتكون ملهمه لما
بتبتدي البنت تنظر الى تفاصيل معينه
متعلقه بحياتها
بشهرتها بجوانب اجتماعيه في حياتها
بشهاده مثلا بانها بتقوم باعمال خيري
بتساهم باعمال خيريه بتشارك في قضايا
مجتمع سوشيال ميديا اتاحت للاجيال دي كلها
انها تشوف جانب اخر في حياه النجوم جانب
براق جانب بيشجع اكتر على ممارسه رياضه
جانب يخلي الشخص ده بالنسبه لي ملهم
الايكون ده انا بحلم في يوم من الايام ان
انا اقترب من المكانه اللي وصل لها فدي من
كبيره جدا للسوشيال ميديا اجيالنا او
الاجيال اللي سبقتنا احنا كنا بس نشوف
البطل في لحظه تنفس الرياضي السلام عليكم
يعني هم خمس دقايق او او على حسب المباراه
مجال او بجريده فقط يعني
لان حتى فكره المجله او الجريده اللي
بتتكلم عن جوانب اجتماعيه في حياته دي
موجوده اكتر كانت في اوروبا يعني هل انا
بيوصلني بيوصلني طبعات من المجلات او
الصحف العالميه في هذا التوقيت ولا لا
بتكلم مثلا عن سبعينات عن تمانينات يمكن
من بدايه التسعينات بدا الانفتاح يكون
اكتر فالجيل الحالي حتى محظوظ اكتر منا او
من الاجيال اللي هي او اجيالكم محظوظه
اكتر من اجيالنا او الاجيال الاكبر انه
عندهم فرصه اكتر يشوفوا جوانب اخرى في
حياه النجوم فرصه
المتابعه يعني في فرصه ذهبيه الان يخلق
حاله من الاهتمام لا وبالمناسبه انا زي ما
قلت نسبه المشاركات في دوره طوكيو
الاولمبيه 49%
احنا خلاص روحنا لمرحله التكافؤ يعني حتى
على مستوى العدد احنا خلاص وصلنا مرحله
التكافؤ 5000 لاعبه اعتقد يعني 5000 لعيبه
من بين 11 الف رياضي في دوره العاب
الاولمبيه في طوكيو ورقم مذهل يعتبر لما
خصوصا لما قارنوا بالبدايات بنتكلم عن
اتنين في الميه
الدوره الاولى يمكن كانوا خمس او ست بطلات
فقط في
التنافس بشكل عام لكن يظل السؤال
[موسيقى]
لان حاله الارتباط بكره القدم حاله جنونيه
والتطور في مستويات اللاعبين كرجال في هذه
اللعبه تطور مذهل يعني يعني كل يوم عندنا
اساليب تدريب كل يوم بيكتشفوا طرق تغذيه
طرق
استشفاء قعدوا قريب وهم اقرب الى الاربعين
بالفعل بينما كانوا يعني في اوائل
الثلاثين
لكن في رياضات رجاليه ونسائيه انا استمتع
بالاثنين يعني كره الطائره للسيدات مثلا
تنافس رائع
يعني انا لو لو لو اخترنا العاب معينه
للسيدات انا بشوف انها بتشد الجميع بدون
استثناء وما فيهاش تفرقه هنروح للالعاب
الجماليه اللي فيها استعراض جمالي جمباز
وغيره
والتناسب من الالعاب اللي هي خلينا نقول
الفتيات او السيدات حققوا فيها نجاحات
كبيره جدا شهره كبيره جدا لدرجه انك
بتذكري اسماء لاعبات تنس
ممكن تتكلمي في اسماء ربما يكافئوا عالم
الرجال يعني على مستوى العدد وعلى مستوى
الشهره مضبوط ولكن خلينا نحكي برضو ما في
تكافؤ فيما يتعلق بعائدات الاحتراف رياضي
ما بين الرجال والنساء مثلا لو حكينا مثلا
على كره القدم او المونديال
الرجالي والنسائي 70% من الناس في العالم
تقريبا
بيتابعوا المونديال الرجال في الميه فقط
يمكن
بتابعوا المونديال النسائي هل ايضا
العائدات هي تلعب دور فيما يتعلق
بالاهتمام والرغبه في المشاركه والرغبه في
التنافس
بتلاقي
الصبيان الصغار بالعمر بيطلعوا على محمد
صلاح او غيره وبيكون العاقل مردود المادي
والشهره هاي الهائله هي جزء من دافعهم
لحتى يصبحوا مثله بينما لانه ما في مردود
ماده هالقد بالشكل الكبير
والمعلن للرياضات والرياضيات النساء
فبالتالي البنات مش كثير مهتمين بفضلوا
يعملوا ثروتهم من الجمال ممكن اكثر من
الرياضه لا انا يعني كلام منطقي جدا هي
دايره خلينا نقول
بتبدا منين بتبدا بالميديا تبدا باهتمام
الاشخاص بتبدا بانتاج لاعبين او لاعبات
على مستوى معين
وبالتالي دعايه اعلانات حقوق صوره هي
دايره كلها متكامله بس فيها جانب ظالم
بالمناسبه يعني انا لما شفت العائد المادي
في التنس مثلا انا رايي في حاله من
التكافؤ في الشعبيه في التنس ما بين
السيدات والرجال دايما انا انا بقول يعني
وبستمتع بمباريات الطرفين يعني اكتشفت ان
السرينه وهي مثلا ان عندها تقريبا 90
مليون دولار الا لم تخون الذاكره عوائد
ماليه في مسيرتها عوائد ماليه مباشره يعني
غير غير الاعلانات غير
عندها 23 جرام يعني عندها 23 بطوله تنس
كبيره اللي هي
اس اوبن بطوله استراليا اللي هي البطولات
الكبيره
اقل منها يعني عنده عوائد 140 مليون يعني
برضو في فجوه في فارق رغم هذه نقطه كتير
مهمه فرق
الاجور ذا قال اللي هي موجوده طبعا على كل
المستويات في كل المهن في العالم تقريبا
تعترض على الموضوع
اكيد معترضين معترضين قوي كمان لازم يكون
في طريقه بس في نقطه مهمه كتير فيما يتعلق
بفرق الاجور وفرق التعويضات والمكافات
للاعبين الرجال واللاعبات النساء بانه
يعني وهذه انا عشان اكون يعني خلينا نقول
صادقه في هذا الموضوع ونعطي كل شيء حقه
طب ما هو مردود صناعه الرياضه الذكوريه
الاكبر وتفوق
يعني في كره القدم مقتنع مليون في الميه
لكن ما يكونش الفرق الى هذه الدرجه كبير
فرق كبير افرز افرزه الواقع افرزته
الصناعه يعني صعد كره القدم الرجاليه تنتج
هذا الكم من المال النسائيه لم تصل الى
هذا المستوى يعني يعني يمكن ذكرت لك مثال
انه
[موسيقى]
اعلى راتب للاعبها في العالم 500,000 يورو
في السنه
للرجال احنا عارفين رونالدو وحتى وان كان
رونالدو على استثنائيه يعني بوجوده في
الدوري السعودي او كذا او في جانب دعائي
من الصفقه او ما غير ذلك ميسي راتبه اعتقد
60 مليون يعني احنا بنتكلم برضو في اضعاف
مضاعفه مقارنه لكن في مجالات او العاب
معينه انا غير متفق على هذا الفارق يعني
ان يكون هذا الفريق بين سيرينا ويليامز
انا بشوفه فارق كبير حتى لو استسلمنا
لفكره ان في فارق بيكون اقل يعني بكلم من
90 مليون يورو ل 140 مليون يورو
النساء دخلت عالم التنس من فتره طويله
ويمكن ارتبطت تنس ارتبطت بذهنيه المتابعين
بالنساء بنفس القدر اللي ارتبط بالرجال
ليش هذا هذا الفرق الهائل ليه صعب نعرف
تفاصيل ده ليه حاصل بس نقدر من حقنا نقول
ان ده مش فقير انه في هذا المجال تحديدا
مش فاهم بس احنا لو خرجنا خارج نطاق
الرياضه
خلينا نقول برضو ما يتعلق بالمراه كمراه
هي ايضا تكسب افضل من الرجل يعني انا
اتصور مثلا في الميديا في الميديا مثلا
دخلها افضل من الرجل ليس لدي معلومه هو
مجرد استنتاج لا اعتقد ربما ربما انا انا
بقول ربما في مجال في مجالات معينه
الاجور في كل المجالات او في بعض المجالات
اكثر من غيرها يمكن في الميديا والتمثيل
والاعلام
ما هذا كله
على حسب يعني في قطاعات لكن احنا طبعا لكن
احنا بنتكلم في الرياضه تحديدا لا انا
بشوف الوضع احيانا في
لاسباب تتعلق بواقع انتاج دائره المال
المحيطه بلعبه معينه واحيانا ما بيكونش
عادل تماما العمل على جذب الاناث من
الفئات العمريه الاصغر فئه 16 ل 24 هم
الفئه الاكثر احتماليه للاجابه بانهم ما
بيملكوا الوقت الكافي لمتابعه الرياضات
النسائيه وعليه فانه دور الاعلام اذا ما
كان حقا يحاول دعم هذا القطاع بانه يسهل
الوصول لهذا النوع من المحتوى عن طريق
تقديمه بطرق سهله كمقاطع قصيره مثلا كافيه
لاثاره انتباه اي متابعه محتمله اسوه بما
نستهلك يوميا لما يتعلق الامر بالرجال
وهناك ايضا اماكن متابعه الرياضات
فالمشاهدات الجماعيه واللي تعتبر ركن
اساسي لبناء قاعده متابعين تبدو جميع
مصممه للذكور وهو اللي بسبب حرج او عدم
ارتياح للمتابعات من الجنس
وهون بودي اني انوه انه مؤخرا بدات تظهر
اماكن مشاهده عامه مخصصه للنساء واهميه
دعمها لضمان استمراريتها كيف بنقدر نزيد
الاهتمام بالرياضه النسائيه سواء كان من
النساء او الرجال ايضا هل منحكي على
يعني
خطوات من الاعلام من السوق بشكل عام حتى
على مستوى العائله للاطفال في المدارس في
التعليم يعني حاسه انه هذا
بقول يعني اشي صعب جدا احنا قلنا بدانا
باثنين في الميه وصلنا 49% في الدورات
الاولمبيه اللي هي مقياس الرياضه الحقيقي
مقياس الرياضه التنافسيه الحقيقي على مدار
التاريخ
احنا عندنا طريقين لمساله الرياضه
النسائيه اللي المساله بتمشي بشكل طبيعي
وسياتي الوقت وهو اتى بالفعل او نكاد نكون
وصلنا يعني نقترب بدرجه كبيره او في طرق
اخرى يعني انا انا واحد من الناس ما بحبش
فكره المحصصه او التخصيص لما بتعامل مع
المراه على انها
حاله استثنائيه زي فكره مثلا يوم المراه
العالمي
احترامي للفكره وانها احيانا بتذكر الناس
باشياء معينه هي المراه ليست كائن
استثنائي كلها يوم يعني ما هي هي المراه
ابنتي واختي وزوجتي ولازم يكون يومها لا
وهي وكل يوم هو يومها بالمناسبه لا انا مش
مختلف
معك وكل يوم يومي ايضا يعني هي الفكره
يعني في اشياء بتتسرب الى العقل دي كلها
تاثير السلبي بدون ان نشعر يعني انا ليه
اعمل لها يوم يعني هل هي استثنائي الى هذا
الحد بالعكس ده هو كل يوم يومها فهي فكره
رياضه من نفس الشيء اذا اذا قررنا ان احنا
نمشي في فكره ان احنا نشجعها بطريقه ما
فاحنا بنتكلم عن جانب اجتماعي الجانب
الاجتماعي محدش عنده الكنترول عليه يعني
التغيرات الاجتماعيه لا يستطيع احد ان
يتحكم فيها ولكنها تاتي بالتدريج مساله
تعليم يعني ممكن التاثير عليها عن طريق
التعليم من من البدايات عندنا مدارس وطبعا
استطيع اهتم بالرياضه النسائيه طبعا
الرياضيه في
رياضه المراه في المدارس على المستوى
الحكومي زي ما قلنا الحكومه تستطيع
الحكومات تستطيع انها تشجع المراه والفتاه
بطريقه ما على ممارسه رياضه درجات تفوق
رياضي في مراحل دراسيه معينه تدفعها
للتفرغ اكثر
للجانب الرياضي ليه لا المدارس مثلا
للمتفوقات رياضيه زي ما بيعملوا بامريكا
تجمع ما بين التعليم وممارسه رياضه في
مستوى الاحترافي مثلا لو المدارس دي انا
كولي امر مثلا ضامن انها فيها درجه من
الامان ودرجه من جيده من التعليم ودرجه
جديده من الرعايه الاجتماعيه والرعايه
الرياضيه انا فورا تكون بنتي في مدرسه زي
دي ويكون عندها تكون بطله تمثل نفسها
وتمثل بلدها ده جانب اخر جانب الميد ده
اتكلمنا فيه يعني المفروض الميديا دم شويه
وبتبتدي تتجرد شويه من فكره ذكوريه
الرياضه
ان شاء الله انا واحد من الناس بيسعدني
جدا اي انجاز لفتاه عربيه على المستوى
العالمي بامانه والله يعني دائما انا عيني
في الدوريات الاولمبيه على الانجازات اللي
بيحققوا عارفه ليه لان هي جايه من بعيد
قوي هي طريقه اصعب مني يعني البنت اللي
بتوصل
لمنصه تتويج وتاخد بنت عربيه بحكي تاخد
ميداليه ذهبيه هي مليون مره تعبت اكتر من
الولد لان مليون مره ظروفها كانت اصعب
احترام اكتر
الاوروبيه او الامريكيه
العالميه يعني هو ده باختصار اللي يودينا
لمرحله ان احنا
نرفع من شان الرياضه نتمنى ذلك طبعا وفي
هذاك الوقت رح نعمل احتفاليه هون في كمان
كلام منطقي ونستضيفك
ونتحدث عن هذا الانجاز الرائع ان شاء الله
اللي راح يكون في المستقبل للاسف وبالرغم
من تقدمنا كنساء عربيا في شتى المجالات
الا انه حالنا ليس بافضل من الوضع العام
العالمي فالمراه العربيه ما زالت تترنح
رياضيا ما بين ضربات العادات والتقاليد
اللي قودت تقدمها لسنين طويله لكن مع
التقدم الحضاري كسرت الكثيرات من نجماتنا
العربيات هذا الطوق وهو ما اجبر الكثير من
الحكومات واتحادات الرياضيه ان تنظر
للتقدم الرياضي هذا بجديه اكثر واقعيه
اكبر كمان على سبيل المثال للحصر بحب اني
انوه واشكر رياضيات الاجيال الماضيه
اللواتي افصحنا الطريق لا الرياضيات
الحاليات وبصراحه صعب كتير اني اتخيل حجم
المصاعب اللي اضطروا انهم يتغلبوا عليها
لحتى يشرقوا في الساحات الدوليه في وقت
كان الرفض العربي هو سيد الموقف لكنهن
ثابرنا وحققنا احلمهن اخص بالذكر هون
حسيبه بالمرقه
وبنيده من راح من الجزائر وفي الجودو
سوريا حداد وسليمه سواركي وغاده شعاع من
سوريا ومن مصر رانيا علواني ونوال المتوكل
من المغرب احنا مدينين كنساء عرب بالكثير
لهؤلاء الرواد واود في مناسبه اليوم
العالمي للمراه اني اشد على ايدي بطلاتنا
العرب الحاليات مثل انس جابر ونهى
الاندلسي وفريده عثمان ونور الشربيني
وحبيبه الغريبي ونهال روحه وامنه القبيسي
وسلوى عيد وشاديه بسيسه في ختام حلقتنا
بحب اني انوه انه على ما يبدو هو قدر
المراه العربيه انها تشقى من اجل حقوقها
وحتى ما ابالغ في عمليه جلد الذات فان
احنا بنشهد مراحل تحول اجتماعي وحضاري
ينذر بمستقبل اكثر اشراقا للمراه عامه
والمراه العربيه خاصه لكن لابد للشركات
ولاعلام على حد سواء انهم يلقوا بثقلهم
خلف هذا الهدف وهو النهوض بالمراه فعلا لا
قولا وكل عام وكل نساء العالم بالف خير
والقادم افضل واجمل باذن الله هذا كلام
منطقي على العربيه
وانا راويه العلمي اشكركم ودمتم دائما
بامان باذن الله
[موسيقى]